[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen OHS and folks there
too
let's close that door that's creepy
right now down the street any mover and
shaker in this business is watching for
they have the Thor premiere and as you
can tell we are here so yeah I didn't
have tickets did you are you gonna try
to pass it off like higher - oh I would
love to come Kevin Feige but now I gotta
go do a show with Kevin Smith yeah I
didn't I didn't get a invite or anything
I don't even know it was happening I
pulled up here and everyone's I was like
sorry there was traffic and this because
the thorah premiere I was like no I
would have been invited to that
apparently not the case I look forward
to seeing that man I've heard a few
people have seen it and [ __ ]
absolutely love it yeah the jacket was
yesterday so a bunch of press saw it and
I hate all of them because I didn't see
well you gave up the press dude I chased
the glory i what were you gonna change I
just got back to Los Angeles it's about
two days ago I went away went to Florida
and did some gigs with Jason and Ralph
and then I went to Jersey for a while
and I went up to New York and had a
meeting with BBC America about this
potential Sam and twitch series
hopefully that gets a little bit closer
avidin knock wood and then the New York
Comic Con was on Thursday so we did a
comic book men panel there and did a
bunch of roundtables with press so I got
to see the boys and stuff and then I did
this thing for Amazon they got a show
coming on called lore I listened to the
podcast
Aaron Mackey's podcast they turned it
into a TV show I don't know if anybody
knows the podcast like Marc does but
it's called lor lor ii and aaron mckie
does this kind
deep dive on horror stories and where
they came from so you know like you
looking for booze just inspecting he
he's like like he does a deep dive on
the first American vampire he does a
deep dive on where werewolves come from
and stuff like that and it's it's pretty
fascinating and and they're all based on
true stories so it's not like there was
really a werewolf but there was a person
who thought they were and that's how it
began and the legend began and stuff so
the podcast is pretty popular it's
putting around for a while
Gale Anne Hurd turned it into a TV show
and it's gonna be on Amazon and I
watched two episodes before I did the
panel I was moderating the panel for him
and I can tell you from the two episodes
I watched they were wholly unsettling
and unnerving in places like so much so
that I had to fast-forward and do this
[ __ ] like you know I know everyone's
like penny wise and Ed he's scared no
he's not he's a [ __ ] clown like that
doesn't scare me but they did a segment
in the episode second episode of lore I
watched which was [ __ ] unnerving it
was entitled echoes and it was about dr.
Freeman I think his name is I don't know
if it's Martin Freeman William Freeman
but dr. Freeman is the American Bilbo
Baggins no just keep taking people up no
he's the guy that invented the lobotomy
and so they have this like it's a they
do it with a series of reenactments it's
mixed-media so they do reenactments with
like actors and then they do animation
Aaron does voiceover they do like the
vintage footage and stuff like that so
it's really [ __ ] interesting to watch
never boring to watch and it's never
like it doesn't feel like an anthology
necessarily like an episodic because yes
there is recreated material but it's
kind of brief in between the other space
and the people they get to be in the
recreations pretty huge like on the
panel was Kristin Bauer Vaughn Stratton
who's you know played Pam on True Blood
the t1000 Robert Patrick he was on the
panel as well Holland Roden from Teen
Wolf so they get like really cool people
I saw one with Campbell Scott he was the
father of the first American vampire
that was the story of like some poor
farmers mana like his whole family at
consumption everyone getting knocked out
and so he had one kid left and his buddy
from down the road was like you got to
talk to this other guy man he had the
same problem he could tell you how to
fix it
and the dude sits down all serious and
he's just like you know it's it's the
devil and right away I like I'll [ __ ] so
they're trying to convince he's trying
to convince Campbell Scott's character
the only way to save his son is to dig
up the dead bodies of his family members
and pull their hearts out and [ __ ]
burn them and so you know the guys like
this is ridiculous but the his sons
wife's like you got to give it a shot
like we did we'd hate ourselves if this
is the last resort we didn't try it and
since its old-timey it's like 18
something they do it like they [ __ ]
dig up the bodies and his wife is all
you know [ __ ] rotted his other
daughter is all rotted then the other
daughter is kind of fresh looking and
they're like hey man she's been in the
ground three months clearly this is the
work of the devil and there's a doctor
who's there's like no he's like we her
body was frozen during the winter and
then we couldn't bury her into the thaw
so yeah she was maintained fairly well
but she'll be rotting she soon enough
and they're like you gonna listen this
medicine man cut her [ __ ] heart out
and they cut that she's dead but they
cut her or they they violate a grave and
violate a corpse cut her heart out and
the guy says put it on the fire and they
burned the heart and then I don't know
where this guy sounds like he's making
it up as he goes along he's like now
take the ashes and make a tonic and feed
that to your son so he took the ashes of
the heart put it in some [ __ ] water
apparently as a tonic is water and
something in it that's it
so they put ashes in the tonic just gave
this did it like [ __ ] and they like
burnt water to drink and he drank it and
you're like you know oh my god is it
gonna work and the voiceover is just
like he died two weeks later you know so
it didn't [ __ ] help at all you know
and the father who'd ever wanted to
bring you know Burberry uh uh what do
they caught dysentery dysentery you know
had to live with the [ __ ] why did we
do that but a news item ran like in a
newspaper like it it means before there
was an Internet somebody wrote about it
going can you believe these [ __ ]
Hicks that [ __ ] believe you could cut
a dead person's heart out and chase away
consumption what idiots and it traveled
to a bunch of different newspapers
including a newspaper clipping that was
found in a notebook a Brahm Stoker so
this is where the vampire myth comes
from the American vampire myth comes
from this story and it extrapolated over
time into you know a man they [ __ ]
like they you know pop out of coffins
and suck your blood and [ __ ] like that
but it began with that weird simple fun
incident so like that was episode 1 but
episode 2 is about the do two invents
lobotomy apparently some guy in Germany
drilled holes in a [ __ ] head first
and then they were like this is inhuman
Germans I know
ten years later in America at 1960 so
this is within spitting distance of when
we were born this guy is he's trying to
figure out like he read an article about
modern-day bedlam bedlam is was the
insane asylum in England where
apparently they just warehoused human
beings like you could pay a penny to
walk through and look at people like it
was a human Zoo and [ __ ] like that
they weren't ministering help they were
just warehousing broken people who
continued to break even more into those
psychotic conditions so there was an
article in Life magazine about a
modern-day bedlam in America so this
doctor is like something has to be done
like look at these conditions these poor
people somebody's got to help them and
that's what lore is very quick to point
out Aaron points out he's like all of
these stories are about somebody that
really want
to do good like it's not about somebody
who's like eat that [ __ ] heart man
minute minute minute man but it was
about somebody being like the only way
to save your son from the devil is to do
this and and this instance was a doctor
who was like if I can help all these
broken people there must be a way and
he'd read about the brain surgery
research and he had done one where you
can open up the cranium and cut this you
know cord between these two sections and
it makes a person more calm as we know
now it makes them lobotomize but that
was too long a process he's like we
can't do it fast enough that way so he
invented the process where they take the
[ __ ] hammer stick it up the eye hole
or whatever and tap tap tap until they
break through the skull and it's crazy
cuz he talks about it in his notes he's
going I understand that medically
breaking a brain sounds like the worst
thing a doctor could do but there's no
other course of recourse for these
people like he actually thought he was
helping and so they depicted in Loris
[ __ ] twisted dude like the dude
sitting there talking to a doctor the
doctor is talking to a woman and a man
and the guy's like I can't handle her
she's out of control she just she but
she won't clean the house blah blah blah
and the doctor is like just lates 1960
doctors like leave her here go across
the street have some coffee come back in
an hour and so you know he's like mrs.
whatever jump up on the table the tables
right in his office and he's playing
like this kind of 60s did it fifties
kind of be-bopping music and so she lays
down and he takes out the you know the
electroshock and so first you're like oh
this is the birth of modern electroshock
that's what this episodes about but he
shocks her and it's [ __ ] unnerving to
watch that and she just [ __ ]
convulsing and that's when he goes for
the lobotomy so you're like holy [ __ ]
and it's so crimson did you hear the
sound like if you watch this episode you
will never not hear the sound of a
lobotomy again in your life it was so
[ __ ] sickening I had to pause it and
I want and woke Jen up and I was like
get up you have to see this
what are you talking about I was like
I'm watching this [ __ ] show for this
Amazon panel and they're doing
lobotomies and she's like [ __ ] off and
she went back to see but she watches all
those programs like on [ __ ]
Investigation Discovery and [ __ ] like
snapped and this feels like a really
classy version of that like with good
actors almost had a really classy
version of snap hi almost man she loves
that shows disturbing I was walked
through the room and she's watching it
and [ __ ] and it's always some section of
the show with her like and that's when
she cut her husband's dick off you know
and I'm like what do you watching and
she's like don't ever cheat and then she
goes back to watching the [ __ ] show
so this is kind of like that cuz those
shows are made with reenactments and
stuff like that no interview no talking
had footage in this know somebody
telling you the story it's done more
artistically so that sequence man
unnerved me and then it ends with like
you know finally his partner's like hey
man like I went and visited some of our
former patients who we think we're
helping and he's like I don't think this
is helping and it came it was 1968 I
guess Thorazine was invented and
suddenly a pill changed everything like
they could give a pill to somebody who
was psychotic and it would calm them
without having to do a [ __ ] lobotomy
so his buddies like we got to put these
lobotomies to the side like maybe it's
time to stop this and the emergence of
Thorazine is probably let's use that as
a good excuse to get out of the [ __ ]
lobotomy business and his partners it's
like you know I stand by our work it's
important like he believed he was
helping people and the last sequence
they show is a woman sitting there
talking to him and it shows 1968 and
she's like you know I can't get him to
do anything he's just he's constantly
loud and stuff I just I can't take it
anymore and I heard that about this
procedure and so what can you do for us
and then doctor goes you know what
there's a coffee shop across the street
just go there come back in an hour
and she's like okay and she leaves and
then they [ __ ] cut to the person in
the chair and it was a [ __ ]
five-year-old kid and he's like get up
on the table and that's how the episode
like [ __ ] it ends and then finally like
he stopped it it was terrifying dude
really and it's it's all based on
[ __ ] reality so I had to do that
panel and all I did was [ __ ] for
20 minutes about you [ __ ] like I'm
gonna live with this year for the rest
of my life but it's wonderful wonderful
show I think it starts to it on Amazon
man and if you're in a creepy [ __ ] give
it a [ __ ] watch so I did that I did
that panel and then Friday I went to
Lana and did a show and then Saturday I
came back to New York comic-con and did
a live show where I interviewed people
for IMDB so I got to talk to the cast of
the tick the cast of Walking Dead the
cast of American Gods Scott Schneider
Greg Capullo Joe Quesada Angela Robinson
who made that movie which I really want
to see comes out this week
professor Marsden and the Wonder Woman
about the creation of Wonder Woman the
guy who created Wonder Woman and the
women who helped him create one of them
so interviewed her as well so it was it
was it was really good man it was like
being there at the comic-con was a lot
of fun Javits Center has packed his [ __ ]
and [ __ ] like that
they had a like I think in Madison
Square Garden they did a Walking Dead
screening and Hardwick did talking dead
afterwards I think they're doing it here
this week to outdoors at the Greek or
something for the hundredth episode of
Walking Dead to do an outdoor screening
and Chris is doing talk about afterwards
so that was on Saturday Sunday I went to
Nashville and did a show at the Ryman
Auditorium and the Ryman Auditorium if
you're unfamiliar with it is that where
they used to host the Grand Ole Opry
they have both kinds of music country
and West Country and Western oh my god
yes my father was big country and
western fan which baffled us for years
because we're from New Jersey and we're
not even from South Jersey where it
might have made sense or something like
that but he just [ __ ] loved country
music and when we were kids he took us
to the Grand Ole Opry it was like his
temple the same way like you know I
wanted to when I was a kid I wanted to
go to Grauman's Chinese Theater or as an
adult I wanted to go to the Northlands
Coliseum where the Edmonton Oilers
played or you know stuff like that that
was his shrine his temple and so when I
was five he took us on a family vacation
there and like I'm or like there was an
opportunity for kids to get on the state
you'd go up on the stage viewer kid so
he's like you're going and he
accompanied me up on the stage because
he wanted to
be there as we're all his heroes used to
sing and [ __ ] like that mall man like
worked for the post office and [ __ ]
we're always real proud of him because
he never [ __ ] killed anybody or
anything like that
and on the weekends like he wasn't this
guy wasn't like way communicative is my
sister says I stole Silent Bob from him
because he never said anything until he
had the right thing to say or something
funny to say and then he [ __ ] off into
the back you know into the darkness
again and [ __ ] so I you know he was
never that guy in terms of you know
chit-chatting about [ __ ] was I hit a
pothole what was I just talking about my
the Ryman yeah he thank you I was like I
got lost in a dad hole which sounds
dirtier than I meant to daddles over
there when he would on the weekends he
would go into his room and play his
records country records and sing and my
father was not that guy he was never a
singer he's never like a show-off of any
kind and stuff so you know I always felt
like it's so weird like who is that guy
that goes in there sings but that was my
real father I met the guy who we had to
put on you know bill I'm your dad you do
what I say and [ __ ] like that what are
you going that room listen that music
that was where he cut loose same way
when I drive around listening to music
free he like Tom Cruise and [ __ ] in
Jerry Maguire that was what my dad would
do in that room so he loved the Ryman
and so I've been doing gigs at The Rime
had not the Ryman at Zanies in Nashville
and Ralphie May who just passed away
this week as well I'd met him on a plane
he was like hey man they're gonna let
you fly that means they let me fly too
and he gave me he was the first person
ever gave me a weed edible I was a
smoker but I never had an edible he's
like take this man he's like you got any
weed I said no he good then take this
and he gave me a lollipop is what's this
he's like you suck it'll get you high as
it really goes yeah or you want to work
fast shove it up your ass
and I've never done an edible so I was
like okay and he goes I'm just [ __ ]
around don't do that he goes unless it
makes you come hard he was funny so when
I did gigs at Zanies in Nashville he
would pop backstage and chitchat and
stuff and so I told him about my dad and
the Ryman he's like well yeah you should
play the Ryman I was like well I'm not a
[ __ ] country star I would have to go
back in time have bad [ __ ] happen to me
and start writing songs in one night and
he said nah I played the Ryman he's like
the comedians do it all the time you
could play the Ryman Auditorium so I was
like nah [ __ ] I got to do that for my
dad one of the last pictures he ever
took in his life he's standing on the
stage of the Ryman he did one on some
online contest and he took my mom to
Nashville and they got to stand on the
stage to take pictures for some fan fest
so I was like I could close some loop
band like I could stand in the same
place my dad stood once and my dad's
hero Hank Williams stood and I stood 40
[ __ ] two years ago when I was a kid
going why are we up here and so I
finally did that gig last night and it
was [ __ ] magical dude it was pretty
amazing my father had been dead like 13
years but I'm pretty sure we had him in
the room I'm not a spiritual cat even
though I made Dogma but the I'm you know
dead is dead that's that you know where
they say on [ __ ] on Game of Thrones
what is dead may never die again
or whatever the [ __ ] thank you so I'm
not that guy that's like I feel my
father but in that room you know like I
said hey man my dad's favorite artist
was Hank Williams like and Here I am on
the stage ranked while I'm sang and and
my father listened albums of Hank
Williams singing on the stage I was like
he's not here he would love this because
moment of dand I did Q&A and [ __ ] so I
was like I'm gonna like I'm not gonna
sing old [ __ ] songs I'm not a singer
I said I'm missing a few bars of I'm so
lonesome I could cry and you guys come
in at the end and stuff so on that stage
where legends have [ __ ] sang and I
have no business being up there singing
I took a moment to sing from oh man and
everyone joined in for the chorus line
of course
and for a minute dude it was I'm sound
like I saw him winking at me not at all
my mom was there she winked at me she's
I go tiger but I felt like if there is
something after this maybe that brought
him back for a second to be like oh [ __ ]
he remembers you know how good so it was
it was beautiful it was a fantastic
night for me and then I came the [ __ ]
home so I can hang out with you what
have you been up to where were you next
time you go first
Massachusetts in the middle of nowhere
Massachusetts on the set of Castle Rock
on the set of the episode of oh I was
sitting there gone a black man in
Massachusetts so wait how was it you
visited the set of Castle mark for those
that don't follow that closely wrote
Castle Rock this year I was on the
writing staff of Castle Rock
so the episode that I wrote was the
fifth in the run and that's what they
were in the middle of production on when
I went up there and it is my second TV
writing job it is the first time I've
been on the set of the show that I wrote
literally like words that I wrote
dialogue that I wrote and then watching
Andre Holland and melanie lynskey and
scott glenn decide not to say them the
director who was such a great story man
I was like how awesome three was great
but so Kevin hooks was the directing
this episode Kevin oats from the white
chef yeah yeah the dude has been
directing at TV for like thirty years
but he was a director and that's so we
didn't rehearse this and Bill skarsgård
was on set Pennywise he was in the show
and Scott Glenn wearing and had the
scene Scott Glenn comes in I'm not gonna
say any of these [ __ ] lines Scott
this is the writer mark
all right I'm not saying so your life I
don't blame you mr. Glenn he's like cuz
I think this you you you want a Scott
Glenn moment I don't do Scott Glenn
moments I do
Alan Pangborn moments I do character
moments I I'm here for the show not for
me did you want a Scott Glenn whoa I
don't even know what that is so you
don't bring it up there's no way you're
not in the position to be like hey man
do the words except that you kind of
sort of our like when you're the writer
on set you are the risk you're the
representative the producers I
technically carry the weight of the show
lawyers when I'm on set really that's
the way it's supposed to go instead I
decided to say which rather than get
into a knife fight with a knife fighter
I decided to say okay well here Scott
here's the thing we need this bit for
the plot hmm we need this bit for the
motion however you want to get there get
it and give him the pertinent
information that he's got a good crust
in the scene juxtapose it any way you
want you gotta get this everything else
is just tap dancing so go for it
anyway before he got it he I think he
was willing to parlay as long as parlay
was on the table
hmm but it was the most surreal thing
I've ever done is to remember like being
in a room with eight other people just
thinking shut up and then six months
later being on set in the middle of
Massachusetts and two o'clock in the
morning making people say [ __ ] that I
wrote it's a unique feeling yes I I was
praying that Andre Holland was not
looking over at me as I was crying
gently and the directors were they tears
of what joy yeah not tears of fear of
Scott Glenn they're different fluids but
not I've been wanting to do this man
since I was like 15 years old who's a
huge moment he was an amazing regardless
of the fact that Scott Glenn was like
hey man it's a lovely lovely
gunslinger you watched your words come
to life yeah yeah
for three days I get to apologize to
everyone for it because we were doing
night shoots hundred people on a set and
they're all [ __ ] and that the cold
snap of Massachusetts winter was kicking
in about 40 degrees and ninety three
o'clock in the morning bees tried to
kill people and they're just like we had
like a bee attack but need people got
stung by 40 bees really yeah like angry
[ __ ] New England bees that's a thing
when we were kids man remember they had
us terrified of the killer bees that
were supposed to be coming yes
Africanized killer bees what was because
that's how you get people scared you
make it black right yeah [ __ ] eyes
[ __ ] is that it's not good drink you can
drinking some of your black were they
called Africanized bee yeah so who did
that I'm not you I mean this guy's on
board but that's [ __ ] up I never heard
that before okay so these were not
Africanized bees these were just pissed
off Massachusetts bees no you know cuz
again black people yeah man I guess that
happens if you go shoot outside
sometimes you have to deal with the
elements and insects and whatnot but it
was it was it was a magical like you
never forget your first time so it was
my first time I remember wasn't my first
time but I remember one time where I was
asking somebody to say words and that I
had written and I was I hit a blue look
at that right like a bar just brought me
a rock star well they didn't want you to
drink it straight out the bottle so
that's what
the where was I I was shooting Jersey
girl and I was talking to mr. Will Smith
who was playing himself in the movie and
giving him a line reading on something
that I've written and he I was like no
no no you gotta say it like this and he
looked at me and he goes and I was like
right you would say it anyway you would
say it cuz it's you saying it right my
bad sorry so that was cool three days I
flew down I drove down to New York for a
New York Comic Con where I spent all the
four hours on the floor which was lovely
do you see anything beyond the floor see
a panel or anything I Sunday was the
Castle Rock panel so all the people that
I saw in the set had flown because
they're fancier than I am down to New
York for the panel for the hour that
they get to say nothing in front of
everybody because they can't say
anything it's a [ __ ] JJ Abrams joint
so it's much everything's unlock down
yes what's it about can't tell you that
it's a supernatural can't tell you that
hey is he playing penny wise can tell
you that it's just yeah lots of
questions without answers
who is the moderator Marisa Rothman from
TV Guide a big a tough job man yeah keep
that going for an hour yeah good luck
but we showed the trailer the first
trailer for this house the look can you
see it online as developers that show
yeah no it dropped a drum just after the
trailer and it's spooky it's [ __ ]
ethereal which was the whole plan
especially cuz we can't say anything
about what the show is
but we know PA playing penny wise
there's no way on earth he's playing
penny wise you play the head game I
think white to be 100% candid and say I
don't know how this show ends
really
my friend Derek is out there's a TV
right easy feels the pain of like oh
you're on staff about 20 weeks and then
they haven't figured out the whole show
and you left and then there's AB you
surprise for everybody that's gonna
that's gonna be fun then for you what
happened and then I get to explain to
the actors so where does this go I know
what do we got on the docket today
there's a trailer I would I was I was
three thousand feet above the ground
flying from New York to LA and I paid
for the second Internet on the flight so
that you could how could you watch it
all the way cuz YouTube you could
actually stream or on Twitter as well I
guess cuz they bloated awful football
game it then became free to the
Internet's so so yeah we saw closer yeah
and what do you think I went online and
watched it on Facebook and everybody
knows what I think I was [ __ ] thrilled
by it man the one thing I can't get over
though is the the fat acts the ones that
are like they've got the bent arms I
call them fat ass cuz they look like fat
dudes doing push-ups they like this so
instead of being like this what do you
think that's about I love that they've
they've evolved from being elephants to
like giant primates scaling up on the
evolutionary do you think that is meant
for climbing or do you think it's meant
to be like if we have them like this you
can't fly under it so anymore Luke
Skywalker or something like that and I
see [ __ ] fat ass climbing up a
mountain at me but why any more than the
abbot like why would you be scared like
only [ __ ] options like why would you I
thought I was cool you think that's
gonna be did you see any of them scale
things no but could you said it you said
primate yeah so we're just fanfiction it
at this point we don't even know what
these [ __ ] things can do like ryan
johnson we're just finishing at this
point it's it's so telling looking at
that trailer
the Justice League trailer which dropped
like a day before that I know just when
Warner Brothers like right on we got a
little traction with our movie Disney's
like look at our big Star Wars dick
[Laughter]
Justice League popping up behind a gun
remember us that just happened it's like
it's like Warner Brothers forgot how to
sell movies explain I I one of my
favorite trailers the last ten years was
Man of Steel trailer the first Man of
Steel trailer yeah when it's you know
it's just Clark he's on a windswept
tableau and you hear like Russell Crowe
when we were all like these movies are
gonna be good Christopher no let's go
something to do with these insects that
is fine too yeah and and and the
voice-over something like they will join
you in the Sun don't be afraid Clark Lee
well they will hesitate they will father
there's that Russell Crowe voice-over
girl it's like I believe this man can
fly like they did their job they sold me
on a new Superman movie and now you
flash forward in almost 10 years and
it's the sky is red and bad wisecracks
and God I hope that Aquaman is cool
because this movie really wants me to
think he's cool and what is the flash
you're looking like that and I don't
understand I want your trailer
commentaries from now on and last Jedi
comes out and gives me almost no plot is
that about plot at all they're selling
me the mood of Star Wars yes what it
feels to be that's a good point I don't
even know what the plot of the movie is
yeah like you get like hints of like oh
shoot little last Jedi clearly Luke
since Mariah Johnson told us but he just
tweeted that Fanny for her was like who
is the last Jedi and he just wrote it's
Luke
[Laughter]
it's got like 10,000 likes cuz people
like yeah man yeah but you know it's
also and then people online were like
they've said it tore up the movies like
at one point
Ryota is like you know when I'm dead the
last Jedi are you I can't do that [ __ ]
but he says like when I'm dead you're
gonna be the last Jedi and then I'm one
of it goes from carpet to Fozzie I was
going for more Ralph's than anything
else about to go and then in the in the
role the front you know roll one of them
says something about the last Jedi and
stuff it's the last Jedi
yeah but yeah it just it it evokes so
much Star Wars while also giving you
some new [ __ ] and then giving you all
the stuff you wanted hey it's a [ __ ]
robot hand then a lightsaber and hey
we're talking about the force and I've
never sensed anybody as powerful as you
yeah watching him get scared is cool cuz
you're like oh [ __ ] if Luke scared we
should all be scared I mean there's a
little bit of a vibe to it in that it's
clear that a decent chunk of this movie
is gonna be ray and Luke training ray
ray [ __ ] up and leaving too early
because that's how this goes is that
what you got from that that's kind of
what I got from that and then there's
other [ __ ] that's happening in the
galaxy are you [ __ ] me I would think
that would be awesome if she did the
same [ __ ] thing he did and then he
could literally be like oh when I was
your age and in the audience we could be
like we saw it like that'd be amazing so
if we could back him up and [ __ ] she
wouldn't hear us but whatever I like
that I hope that's what happens I didn't
get that from the trailer at all though
really I know this much I bet my life on
this one meant of my life cuz I'm wrong
some [ __ ] will shoot me but I'll
put a hundred bucks on the fact that the
last two shots in the trailer are not
connected where he's you know she's like
help me and then they cut to him and
he's putting his hand out bullsh
there ain't no fire behind her or
anything like that they're two different
places but I do think they are telling
the truth about the moment with kylo Ren
in the Darth Vader looking TIE fighter
about to shoot Princess Leia
that oh my god I mean look it was
heartbreaking I'm wonderful as he carry
back and stuff but you know in that
moment that's the Princess Leia moment
to me yeah and if that's how they figure
out like how to go out with the
character like that just makes kylo Ren
the most hated [ __ ] in the world since
Joffrey you know what I'm saying like
just really hate the [ __ ] because he
took out two of our childhood favorites
and [ __ ] and you know and then maybe it
[ __ ] Luke kills him it's all good
in the third one who knows I'm sure they
got writers well he's not gonna die
Luke why because if Star Wars is about
anything it's my Redemption
it's about clawing somebody back from
the abyss it's I mean the whole [ __ ]
first six movies are about saving Darth
Vader it's about the the Fallen rise of
a man right I don't see a world in which
you let Luke Skywalker's son as bad as
he is be killed but sorry on so some
let's go what's nephew but yeah but like
it's it's this is a saga about
Redemption it's a saga about saving
people sorry about not letting letting
go of hope right and so I don't see a
world in which we kill kylo Ren that's
whatever now why I mean old age maybe
does he he doesn't [ __ ] nobody makes
him pay for the murder von solo
I mean he'll die but not because
somebody kills him he'll sacrifice
himself in the same way that Darth Vader
dies but not because he gets killed but
because he gives himself I'm sorry did I
spoil something
I like the trailer quite a bit and
you're right I still don't really know
what's going on in the story but it
makes me want to see it yeah
the Justice League trailer did not
really do I've keep watching the Justice
League trailer because I know sooner or
later yeah sooner or later it's gonna
make me go like [ __ ] yeah I'm in like
they got my money I'm going regardless
and stuff but it seemed like the same
trailer I didn't here's what I remember
people smiled more in this trailer
there's like a couple shots like where
they intentionally like the people will
smile you will believe a man could smile
and they'll cut till like the flash
smiles and wonder woman smiles Batman I
think kind of smiles at one point [ __ ]
like that everybody got a smile going
and stuff Clark smiles Lois smiles it's
all [ __ ] smiles man so justice laughs
of America they're still hiding the fact
that Superman is in this movie yeah but
I thought it was a classy selling the
trailer with a like hey we're not saying
Superman's back but Clark is in her
dreams and [ __ ] like that it's good way
to say he's gonna be there without
[ __ ] saying some people don't like my
mom wouldn't know so she could go into
that movie and be like Oh tiger
Superman's back from the dead but yeah
you're probably right
they [ __ ] at this point and that was the
last trailer they're saying probably I
mean there's gonna be bunch of TV spots
in which they will show Superman you
think so where the look areas please
give us your money a man when is it
November yes and then Star Wars is
December 7 three days after the fourth
when is when is Thor throws out the
third so wait Thor comes out and then
what 1/7 they get make it two weeks it's
Thor does it's two weeks and then
justice it comes out and all reports of
Thor are amazing yeah so it's not like
it's gonna hurt it at the box-office
yeah all right what else we got
what's next well The Punisher was
supposed to have it be
la-dee-da in New York comic-con they
were and then the events in Las Vegas
changed that yeah and it also Marvel was
doing a licensed comic book with Grumman
the people who make airplanes and also
lots and lots of guns and it seems as if
people kind of twitch to the fact that
maybe do any Marvel comic book
glorifying firearms was not in the jam
at the moment I could see the temptation
right with like well Tony Stark makes
weapons so it is entirely possible that
oh it wasn't Punisher it was Avengers ya
know to urine Tuvan stories they stopped
the Avengers panel because of the Las
Vegas shooting and the book was an
Avengers crossed over with that company
and they had their own superheroes and
[ __ ] like that
and that was their point they're like
wow it made sense to us because Tony
Stark makes weapons and they make
weapons but now we see that everyone's
mad so sorry yeah it does make me wonder
if they will stall the release of The
Punisher a little bit cuz there was talk
that it would be out for Veterans Day I
believe which is November which makes
all the sense in the world so I can
Frank Castle ya know veteran that are
involved but I get the feeling that they
might push it if I was them until next
year I'm gonna get away with it it's not
like it's gonna like people have been
like I'm not interested anymore
like and sadly though the way the news
cycle goes something is going to happen
this week and people will probably be
like oh yeah Las Vegas didn't that
happen we're shooting an American
history
[ __ ] what a horrible time to be alive it
is man a couple of years ago I felt like
this is the greatest time in the world
to be alive and and I'm it's this is not
a trump statement at all and I'm not
saying like under Obama it was great but
a few years ago I didn't feel this
impending sense of dread and you know
wondering if like waking up every
morning yeah if there is gonna be a
nuclear war again like it's [ __ ]
crazy man I'm not again we've never had
a nuclear war but I had fears when I was
a kid yeah you were there that day oh
that was the day after my bad but I had
fears as a kid and now they're kind of
back and [ __ ] like that the news is just
[ __ ] so shitty so more pop culture
what's next
[ __ ] I just want to hide in the ass of
this [ __ ] later 2049 oh yeah
that's a commitment of time almost three
hours they saw us did anybody else say
it did you guys like it she saw it twice
Wow what could you have been doing with
those five hours in stand you sneak
Blade Runner twice I liked it it's I
loved it even news I love him as well I
think I love the rival what was it
prisoners prisoners Sicario and Sicario
but arrival is [ __ ] genius man I mean
I love Michael Green to do two who
co-wrote it with Hampton Fancher yeah
and has murder they were an Express
later what next he's got a huge year
he's got the [ __ ] year of all years
the movie to me it's weird because it's
basically about a bunch of Pinocchio's
who wish they were real boys okay which
is really interesting but kind of
dramatically sterile you know like
nobody is really alive in this movie
like everybody's kind of acting behind
these sort of veneers of either I'm not
a real person or I am Jared Leto or I am
some kind of a I [ __ ] construct it is
not until Harrison Ford shows up 20
minutes before the end of the movie
where it's like oh [ __ ] that's right
that's what a human being is like on
screen that's what it's like to see
somebody who wants something and he's
feeling it and you're seeing it on his
face mm-hmm I think it's an amazing
exercise in something that is not even
at its zenith that fulfilling but I
think it's an amazingly done movie like
it's beautiful to look at you know it is
the movie was it's the best version of
this movie was gonna be but I've also
talked about how I don't love the first
Blade Runner yeah it's definitely a
movie I respect more than enjoy it's not
like let's [ __ ] it get high and watch
Blade Runner that's a celebration of
life here's my big question I'll see the
movie but and and spor this will be
spoilers so if you don't want to know
this don't know it today reveal if
Deckard was a replicant or not because
he
they do they do they make a very alright
sure they absolutely do no he's saying
they reveal he's not saying what the
reveal is hold on oh wait this that's
coming from people saw the movie did I
not missed the whole point that the
child that they're looking for is a
hybrid between a replicant inhuman and
see that [ __ ] on the [ __ ] tagline
yeah right you think you know a guy and
if Rachel is this child's mother and
she's the replicant
then if it's a hybrid then the other
parent has to be human this is the
[ __ ] magic this is how this works
it's human DNA and replicant DNA and we
got a replicant gave birth to a baby
that's just wait two and a half hours
how did they handle Rachel
lots of archival footage until they get
like some ridiculous that convincing
body double towards the end so they
represent her yeah really yeah yeah
might actually how come and show that in
the trailers or anything cuz that would
be a big spoiler oh is it a big [ __ ]
yeah well done alright I will say I
don't know if honestly I don't know if
I'm gonna go to the theater though
that's a long sit man it's a long sit
but I mean it's worth it for the theater
because it's so [ __ ] pretty that's
true maybe I'll go for that it's
what's-his-name who shot it this is the
year he might actually win two Academy
Awards never won one before even though
he's a genius
alright you you know what you sold me
I'll go see in the theater for Deacons
man seen on the big city give it up
Apple is close to a deal on making a new
Amazing Stories TV show oh really yeah
that all the old 80s Steven Spielberg
chanology Bryan Fuller is apparently
going to be executive producing good
choice did you ever watch that show as a
kid what is it did I watch amazing
stories yeah I was just thinking of
anthologies at this point man
jeez they're [ __ ] huge and I think
they're easy did it go out yeah you have
Mandel
wait where was it was I just talking
about Anthology I think they're easier
to digest and like a binge watch of a
show that's like now you've got to watch
the next episode because it's all
connected and stuff so I think like for
a while people nobody wants to do
anthology like anthologies [ __ ] dead
but I think like thanks to shows like
Black Mirror it's back in a big bad way
that's what lore is set up as an
anthology as well because you can sit
and think about it when you're in a 10
12 episode of binge life [ __ ] stops
you don't shower everything's terrible
but with an episode like with that
anthology you can watch one [ __ ] off and
then the next one's completely different
anyway and stuff like that I could see
that working
did your mic start working yet or no oh
[ __ ]
alright back to you thanks chip in
traffic let's see you know there was
supposed to be a dark universe of movies
that Universal was doing Universal has
very quietly pulled Bride of
Frankenstein off the release schedule
yeah so the dark universe just got real
dark
yeah Universal statement was this kind
of [ __ ] after thorough consideration
Universal Pictures and director Bill
Condon have decided to postpone Bride of
Frankenstein none of us want to move too
quickly to meet a release date when we
know this special movie needs more time
to come together
grade-a [ __ ] right there yeah they
slung it something fierce well I think
that has everything to do with how and
crazy-crazy well the mummy did what was
the what was the movie for The Mummy
Dracula something and now this like
nobody seems to really give a [ __ ]
really like it seems like the yeah and
if you're gonna do the Universal
Monsters like do the Universal Monsters
like they did a mummy movie that was
like Tom Cruise is not the mummy like
and the movie became all about him and
[ __ ] like that so I don't know I I do
think you could make cool movies these
characters I just think these attempts
have been [ __ ] unnecessarily huge and
expensive and I know that you're on to
make tentpole movies but I don't think
you need to go that far you know maybe
it's best they let it rest for a minute
or so but remember how they were selling
it so hardcore where they had all the
stars get together and take that picture
and stuff oh god I don't think they were
together I think it's one of those
Photoshop jammie-jams where it's like
we're not gonna get Javier Bardem and
Tom Cruise and Johnny Depp is in [ __ ]
Vienna shooting it Murder on the Orient
Express movie now we're gonna cut and
paste these [ __ ] in the same
frame I totally believed it all got
together in one room this movie's must
be special I said who knew all right so
that's sad what's what's what's next
well we could talk about Westworld
season two you guys care about Westworld
season two
I do if for season two they are teasing
the showrunners Jonah Nolan and his wife
Lisa joy that we will see Roman world
and medieval world in a season two evil
this is evil world I was like what hell
that'd be amazing yeah
all right so Roman world and medieval
when they a tease what about Shogun
world we saw that yeah they sees like
samurai planet or whatever that was at
the very tail end of the first season
but that's that's that's all that I have
from [ __ ] West world news that show
looks [ __ ] expensive they're spending
all of HBO's money really yeah I mean
the ones the dragons aren't spending
they're spending it on West world I was
gonna say man I'm certain to be Lulu
what the [ __ ] is going on Jesus Christ
I did I was it was a classroom okay what
else that's all we got news Wiseman
that's the news that's the news it
depresses all news folks that means we
turn to you guys for the content hands
in the air wave really you just don't
care starting right there how do we feel
about sci-fi picking up deadly class
yeah Rick Rick Remender 'he's comic book
so the Russo brothers of Avengers movies
Fame are producing a TV version of
deadly in class which is like a boarding
school for assassins and it's a book is
it a okay and so there and when did they
denounce this [ __ ] well you know what
you're fired
you're
this is gonna really go you guys I just
have to pretend to be a black guy for
the rest of your life so that's gonna be
sci-fi so now sci-fi has that show and
are magicians happy
Happy's coming and Krypton's coming is
right that's a full slate they are
trying to be the CW they should have
been 10 years ago there are new manifest
their new manifest is it's a fan thing
it's fan we're fan right because the
fans don't want like wrestling were they
running wrestling yeah they were
wrestling they had a cooking show once
it was like molecular kitchen or some
[ __ ] like that because they thought that
I mean nerds like to eat why don't we
have a cooking show they don't like to
watch it they got that brand name and
like sci-fi is like even though they
spelled it a couple different ways are
you pointing to me what why do you use
windows that's my [ __ ] all right yeah I
I heard about it I'm excited for cuz I
think it's a great book it's just the
green lettuce script that they were
gonna shoot a pilot for who knows if
they'll make it a series or not I hope
they do because there's there's a
there's a long there's a long road of
stories you could tell about deadly
class it's it's really sharp so fingers
crossed but we've talked about before
the likelihood of a thing that goes to
pilot actually becoming a TV show which
is not to say slim the [ __ ] is going on
here
it's like a bar in the Old West let's
have a fight
[Applause]
damnit clemmy's would all right where
we're gonna go next thing brought gifts
hi hey bring it on up man
but handle first please
that is badass
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you why what are we do deserve
this I am I am gonna go commit some
Batman Forever crime tonight do you guys
making selfies yeah where can we send
people who want one of these show the
prototype this is not a prototype this
is some frickin money double [ __ ] Ripper
blades are IP ber river blades not
[ __ ] hell listen officer oh I was not
driving with this on purpose
a dude gave it to me at the show
[Music]
it's like principle that's a babe saver
that's a vape as well a vape saver
that's pretty fantastic use the blunt
loop Ripper bling why
oh [ __ ] is to keep thank you so much Wow
my son is gonna be so jealous if he
can't touch my [ __ ] light-up swords
[Laughter]
yo good how are you
fantastic did we talk about this before
we did we did but we can recap briefly
I'm all for it especially because he put
me in the last one so I think JJ's a
great director I think he did a great
job with force awakens is tough a tough
road oh and totally worked made people
excited about Star Wars again hey the
lights have been JC so I'm excited as
[ __ ] man I'm glad I honestly didn't
understand why he wasn't doing all of
them and then I figured it was because
timing like it would take too long to go
from one to the other to the other so
they gave him the three different people
so I'm glad that he gets to finish it
out what about you I'm on board because
bad robot pays my checks I mean I do I
do as we said last time I do feel like
there was an opportunity to give it to
somebody who was both not JJ but might
not [ __ ] it up in the same way that
apparently they've had a problem finding
directors who won't [ __ ] it up my
fingers were crossed for Ava Duvernay
given that Disney is in love with
wrinkle in time and did Star Wars is a
Disney jammy-jam it would have been nice
to see a different flavor like to see a
female take on Star Wars to see an
african-american take on Star Wars but I
it's you cannot fought the logic of JJ
so
and and the lens flare and he pays me
money so he is the modern-day George
Lucas Steven Spielberg I so yeah I'm all
on board man I can't wait but that being
said I think Brian's looks wonderful
based on that trailer like honestly I
think the first trailer for me I was
like yeah okay Star Wars of course I'll
be there
but this cherry got me real excited
especially when it's like is he gonna
kill the hell is he gonna [ __ ] kill
my off my dog wouldn't answer me
no man no answer how are you thank you I
agree Manta and thank you for that I'm
sure with Mark thanks she was all mad
you'd speak for me really thank you I
agree though man that's one of my
favorite things about doing the show is
when Mark gets right early because I
like to think of myself as a writer but
I'm not a traditional writers write [ __ ]
a goofy [ __ ] about me so it's nice to
like hear what a real writer thinks
especially as I had possibly toured like
you know if Sam and twitch winds up
being an episodic TV show like
everything he said to me over the last
few years is sank in and of course he'd
be working on it as well so then Kevin
Smith should direct the next Star Wars
because then you can be paying their
money that's how this goes they were
like you can have it and we'll pay you
all the money to do it I don't think I'd
be interested in that but that [ __ ]
takes a long time you know what I'm
saying and it seems like a lot of work
you know what's easier is to watch it
and then make jokes about it later on
that's that's kind of my thing in life
yeah or you could take it then get fired
off it yeah over there yes
[Music]
let me see the closest I ever got to
what we did a clerks animated series and
they aired too and then [ __ ] off is
James ssambap super-groovy cartoon movie
I still get checks for we do really yeah
we've 38 cents that's not bad I'll take
it we've done like small donation shorts
and stuff like that but nothing like
hero oriented I wrote a script for
Warner Brothers animation for a plastic
man pilot for a episodic pilot which I
was told recently they're not doing so I
wish you know there was never like is
it's possible they were there there were
a bunch of [ __ ] and they're like we're
just not ready for plastic bin right now
but I liked what I wrote and stuff but I
you know no there's there's never been
anything that I like I honestly if I
watch an episode of Rick and Morty it
cures me of any desire to think I could
be in cartoons to like they've taken the
medium [ __ ] transcended with it
I don't think so like I you very sweet
but a Rickon Kevin Smith Rick and Morty
would sake I love watching that show at
the end of it I'm just like like I
couldn't do that like the same way I
felt about Simpsons when I was younger I
was like I love watching it could never
write that like my brains not set up
that way and stuff so I get to look up
to it admirers it's nice to have [ __ ]
like that you can just like without
being like oh I want to be involved so
often in life I fall in love with things
where I'm like who I want to be involved
and I put my [ __ ] shitty smeary paint
all over it and stuff like that so it's
nice to have some [ __ ] like that I'm not
involved in you know I'm saying I could
still always just appreciate it from a
distance nothing wrong with being a fan
you don't always have to be [ __ ]
involved you know I'm saying so that's
what I tell myself take
Rick and Morty I'm like I not just
fricken more just animation in general
like enjoy the people that do it because
you can't do it like that that's why I
sell to save myself
as for 90's cartoons I was not a big
x-men guy I that was Jason Mewes he had
every episode recorded and stuff I had
every episode of Batman the Animated
Series recorded that was my job I was
we're gonna quick stop when it started
airing and I had taken to bringing a TV
into the convenience store after my boss
is left I'd bring a TV in from the car
and stuff and then since there was a
video store next door I started bringing
in a VHS as well so I could just take
movies and watch them while I was
working at the convenience store so then
I would go next door to the video store
it was the first they air in two
episodes I think at night of Batman and
then it went to an afternoon scheduled
on Fox by remember correctly so I would
go set the turn the VCR on and [ __ ]
record every episode and collect them
all and and I loved it because it was so
true to the books like more true to the
books than the movies were being like it
just felt like a comic will come to life
and Kevin Conroy's depiction of Batman
was was it like you know you'd heard
others but this was the that was the
voice of Batman so much so that from
there forward every time I read a comic
book that's the voice I hear when I read
Batman it's Kevin Conroy voice and Mark
Hamill is the Joker and so so oh my god
like it treated the material seriously
with respect like it didn't make clowny
cartoons they it also looked beautiful I
mean I know a lot of people swear by
those excellent cartoons but those
Batman cartoons look a thousand times
better like the x-men cartoons look like
coloring books and that's not bad they
were kids cartoons but with Batman the
Animated Series they were trying for
something else something artistic at the
table at the same time and they had a
lot of faith in their audience even
though they were making a kids show they
were they weren't like these kids are
stupid so we have to tell them what's
going on every step of the way
it's not a nuance in those stories man I
mean think about the heart of ice story
mr. freeze story it's not really for
children
at all but it works it doesn't scare
kids and [ __ ] like that it's great
Batman's story for kids like whoo this
is where Mr Freeze comes from but it's a
[ __ ] tragic story about like love
gone wrong and stuff and a villain who's
a victim himself so that that was the
highest bar I'd ever seen set in
animation and I don't in terms of
superhero animation I don't know that
anybody's touched it since
there definitely been some wonderful
cartoons and I loved Batman Brave and
Bold I thought it was a real love letter
to Silver Age comics and stuff like that
and I love Diedrichs Batman but I I
don't think it's ever been as good as it
was with Batman the Animated Series man
that was like a dream team of creators
like coming up with not just characters
that existed in the Batman universe and
defining them coming up and adding
spokes to the wheel we only have Harley
Quinn because of Batman the Animated
Series so that's that's that's my
religion now and and anything that I was
into before I started making movies I
always hold doubly affection
affectionate towards because it was I
was a fan you know what I'm saying now
because now I make stuff you get access
and you get to see things early and
people send you stuff and show but I
worked for my Batman the Animated Series
fandom yeah Grant said the work was
running over to the video store which
was only 30 steps away and she hadn't
recording but like I kept my [ __ ]
cataloged and whatnot I went out of my
way for it so it always reminds me of
like this wonderful time my life I love
mega movies and [ __ ] like that but there
was a minute right before we did any of
that stuff which is like my favorite
part of my life and Batman the Animated
Series is really tied up in that mark
Thundercats are awesome my my cartoon
growing up was reruns of the old Warner
Brothers Looney Tunes stuff I love that
show too like I would I would clean my
room every morning every Saturday
morning so that I could be ready for
9:00 a.m. when they would start and you
just get him for an hour and that was it
and I try to explain to my son
I had to like tune in at a specific time
for a thing that would never happen
again because that's the way life works
it's just like there's no on demand is
no DVRs that nobody mean have a VCR
these were the olden days but yeah it
was that and Batman I mean I was working
at Starlog magazine when I went Batman
animated series started and I remember I
was yeah you collected checks that's in
store yeah you want to see my back
issues yeah I remember when it premiered
and we did like 98 stories on it because
we started like magazine we were [ __ ]
nerds for it and then in the 2000s like
I fell in love with this show called
Avatar The Last Airbender it is no but
they didn't watch it with me because
they they resist it in every turn the
thing I thought it was cool just me
sitting down watching Nickelodeon like
what's dad do what he's watching your
[ __ ] why are you gonna like it but it's
it's an amazing piece of literature it
really is like if it was if it was my if
if I was seven when that had come out
and that would have been my Star Wars
like it is that deep but is that mythic
it is that sort of foundationally smart
and strong
like if yeah I mean and and Legend of
Korra which is the sequel to it is is
equally strong but from a completely
different angle and it's a different
energy to it but it's it is it his
cartoons of the highest caliber I cannot
say that highly enough so yeah
Thundercats and Jojo when nobody ever
dies yeah [ __ ] yeah rise of Serpentor
and [ __ ] the weather Dominator [ __ ] yeah
like it was I was like 11 or 12 and it
was a it was a weekly what a 71 second I
wasn't watching GOG
that's a question for you and your God
sir I remember my friend who came down
for the summers he had a bungalow across
the street from our house I grew up in a
town in the Jersey Shore called
Highlands and so Pete's family they
lived in Brooklyn hmm and his dad worked
for con Edison the Power Company so
during the summer they would come down
and stay at the summer
fungal and stuff so me and Pete Ken he
was right across the street used my
summer my summer best friend
he loved Star Wars made all the toys his
parents got him everything and she liked
that so we played Star Wars all the time
and you know I was like you would play
the movie and then you would start
making up adventures and she was the
birth of creativity that's how you learn
to be a writer man like a lot of people
like all you give a kid toys from a
movie there's no invention there that's
not at all true like you know I I had
whole [ __ ] adventures where Luke and
Leia got married that was [ __ ] up
later on got to use my imagination and
stuff like that so I yeah therapy came
later so it was Pete got into GI Joes of
certain point he transitioned away from
Star Wars circa like 83 have to return
the Jedi he was kind of like well that's
it stuff and he was getting more and
more into GI Joe and you know that I
didn't follow so we kind of stopped not
stopped playing I still see him go okay
what's up
but I didn't follow him into the GI Joe
obsession he had like the [ __ ]
aircraft carrier you're like wow
hardcore a fan of the show and believed
it he would always charge that he gotta
watch it man and so it's cool it's
connected it's like Star Wars but he
said that about everything you know he's
like you gotta see Snoopy come home it's
like Star Wars you'll cry passed away
died he stepped off a curb in New York
going to CBGB's back in the day and a
cab
clipped and [ __ ] killed it man it's
crazy yeah promise me out of all the
time whenever I think about Star Wars
and now I'm making all these new stores
even [ __ ] they're talking about Boba
Fett so long movie young Yoda
[ __ ] like that like that was the guy I
shared Star Wars with the most this
would be an amazing time your him like
we used to [ __ ] play Boba Fett like
[ __ ] going through all the movies
like you know even though he wasn't in
Star Wars and [ __ ] like that and playing
trapped in time and stuff so he's always
like it that'd be cool if they did that
and now they're doing a movie would be
badass if they put over Fett all
throughout the Star Wars universe like
in places he never was led just hanging
out in the back well he's got like a
time device work suddenly he's in rebels
you know is Boba Fett a Time Lord now
like many Star Wars movies a week to
make the money back so like this be one
of it all right so wait cartoons I feel
like we've no there was a the rise of
serpent I remember was a daily
miniseries it was like Monday through
Friday every day was a chapter in this
story which we then collected later on
as a whatever the [ __ ]
and then transformers I was big into
transformers are you a robot person
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's no I just like to naked of
merchandising sell to me you know like
he-man was another fault a whole I
didn't follow them it's weird because
like that seems like a naked grab for
money whereas Star Wars and my all my
Star Wars figures never occurred to you
well this is serious it's based on a
[ __ ] what do you have 18 boxes of
Cheerios in the house I gotta [ __ ]
cut out these for purchase so I can send
Kenner so I can get the [ __ ] ig-88
doll because otherwise there's no way to
get this doll but that wasn't a play for
toys was there was I to send away yeah
it was yeah
it's a it's a massaging aid not a dildo
personal massager somebody sneak some
[ __ ] through the mouth now mom I bought
a personal massager all right where do
we go next
right they're not that far back we were
just there first let me see I think I
mean I wanna I wanna I want to put rode
one high but only because of one minute
of the film so I don't know give it a
second spot let me see I go Empire I go
force awakens I go Star Wars Jedi and
then put the prequels in well I'd go
reverse I go sit clones and then I think
that's you I go I go New Hope first oh
really
yeah because for my money there was
still not a moment in any of those films
that is as magical as the Millennium
Falcon streaking out of the Sun during
the Death Star trench run it's like you
clear yeah like that that is the first
time I ever felt chills in a movie
theater and I was like seven and I'm
like I don't know what this [ __ ]
means but this is amazing I want all of
this all the time
it is the most heroic thing I think I've
ever seen in a movie well yeah yeah Han
Solo is for me the hero of those films
because everybody else is born into it
like Luke Skywalker was going to be a
Jedi because his dad was a Jedi like the
forces within him because it's within
him same thing with Leia
its genetic for them han Solo chooses to
be in this adventure you know despite
and they'd be [ __ ] without him like he
he could have walked away he should have
walked away life would be better for him
if he walks away but he gives up
everything to be in the rebellion and
that for me is what makes a hero
not somebody who was born to be a hero
it's a dude who wakes up and says you
know it's fun I'm gonna do the right
thing even though it makes the worst
sense for me right now so that is the
most heroic console has ever been so
that's my favorite of the movies then
it's hold on huh before you go further
yeah just deserves applause so yeah new
hope empire force awakens Jedi Koza V
walks safe phantom attack of the clones
attack of the clones is the worst of
those [ __ ] movies why because there's
I mean it doesn't even introduce
anything I need like a very least the
first movie Phantom Menace dumb as it is
stupid boob jokes is Amaya have I meet
Anakin Skywalker for the first time I
meet obi-wan Kenobi for the first time
it has things that I never saw before
tiger the [ __ ] clones is [ __ ]
just all [ __ ] soup two mouths
beating man it's like a detective story
with bad detectives what are we doing
finding a clone army gives a [ __ ] why
why even Lucas who said it's his least
favorite of them all is that the one
where beg to go he goes to see that
space chicken at the diner because he's
following leads that was the first ball
yeah it felt like an episode of [ __ ]
it's Mambo it just
it's it's Magnum Jedi is what that is
right here let me look at this piece
well there's a different galaxy it was
it was the real it stood out especially
because it's like wall this is CG even
the little robots EGA yeah it's just all
[ __ ] they're all the arena yeah yeah
you know out of nowhere she's like I
love you that's that's thing like your
skin is so soft unlike sand which gets
everywhere yeah it's that [ __ ] it's
George Lucas has never been in love so I
was trying to write a romance or he's
trying to remember back to when he was
in love and he's like I think I talked
about sand a bunch sandwich which is the
one that I'm going to bump with
hopefully it moves forward but that's
that's the only thing I was involved
with buckaroo banzai and then stepped
away because they were creators weren't
being involved so hopefully they cleared
that up and I get to work on that again
one day but right now that's the only
thing I'm working on if I understand the
question correctly I have a comic book
that I'm still writing called genius
that's coming out through top count
image that as creator owned that belongs
to me and my writing partner that we are
starting to talk to people and Hollywood
about Hollywood things what is like I've
never done that it's like here's my
thing and I'm gonna try to show it to
you like yeah it's it's it goes both
ways it goes the way right now we're in
the a process where we're building a
pitch and we're gonna take it out and do
the town and say here's our thing we
want
TV show the other side of that is we
have the IP it belongs to us and people
come to us saying we read your book
really lucky we want to make it into a
movie
here are the 18 things you want to
change about it and for us it's always
the which of these things can we
tolerate and which of these won't we
tolerate you know and the thing we're
always the most protective of is the
reason why you fell in love with the
project to begin with you can't change
that so if this book happens to be about
a girl who is the greatest military mind
of her generation but she's 17 years old
and lives in South Central and she
decides to declare war on the LAPD and
sustain three square blocks from the
Union through force it has to be the
LAPD it has to be a girl has to be now
it can't be after an earthquake you
can't be in the future it can't be what
if it's private security no like you
lose all of the things that make that
idea that was the story yes that's what
story okay cool man
yeah and like we pitched this book in
2007 the first issue came out in 2009
and nobody wanted to publish it
everybody was like hey it's got a black
lead it's got a female lead and a comic
nobody wants those and you're killing
cops like let me just gonna buy this and
chop cows roll the dice and it came out
and it did well enough and then [ __ ]
Ferguson happens and then suddenly it's
oh [ __ ] so there is police brutality oh
[ __ ] so there is a sort of systematic
initiative that seems to be devaluing
certain segments of the population as
opposed to others there is moments where
we see tanks rolling down residential
neighborhoods and we see militarized
police actions and suddenly what was
unthinkable in 2007 is now just the news
and so there's this whole new life to it
and that's why we're sort of dusting it
off and taking it out because it is not
as hard to sell as it was ten years ago
for the most awful reasons but asking
like do you bring the comic book we eat
so yeah there's there's a couple things
like I've been doing comics for about
ten years and there's the Marvel stuff
and there's the DC stuff but then
there's the handful of [ __ ] that I've
done on my own
that belongs to me that that you know
under right circumstances ie
Brinks truck full of cash will I sell
them I directed he's gotta sign those
checks right there what Tiffany's been
having a question for the longest time
how do I write somebody who's supposed
to be smarter than I am I cheat some of
it is research some of it is like
looking back and all right well how the
[ __ ] did Hannibal take Carthage how the
[ __ ] did Alexander take whatever how did
I was [ __ ] literally as we're talking
I was like Hannibal
totally that's the only but but it's
it's a bit like plotting a mystery in
that you start with the whodunit you
know look I know in this story who kills
Colonel plumb and the whatever the [ __ ]
and then I just worked backward to hide
the clues like if I've got to make sure
she wins I know she's going to win so
let me just you know serpentine my way
back through the story to make it look
surprising and inevitable you put way
more thought into your writing but like
and there's no like here the theme I was
texting with Dan Harmon about coming
over the house doing a podcast and he I
want to deep dive with him because he
seems like the guy who was also very
like what's the hero's journey here's
the arc like they take the writing
serious he's got I think it's a clock
style diagram for every episode of TV
that he does where every quarter of the
clock is a different phase of the story
and it's like you hear start here and
here
first complication here is the you know
first resolution and then here is
different like it's it's mathematics for
him after a while I want I wanted to get
inside his his head because I liked that
show and I heard about that process I
was like that's treating it very
seriously yeah when I sit down right I'm
like oh let's make some giggles but
that's like somebody gon like you gotta
be precise and there's a formula to this
kind of sure you haven't text him with
him and he was like you know as I came
in you free and get back to me and then
he got back to me it's like hey I'm free
and I said I'm in New York he's like Oh
[ __ ] tomorrow and he goes we are like
two spies in the night so I some be in
Los Angeles next week it's like I'm
gonna be in Los Angeles but like it's
one of those things where you know like
I think of myself as a writer and then I
hear that I'm like oh is that what
writers do yeah I mean it's what writers
do who have to do this over and over and
over again why because after a while
like I'm not gonna say not to squeeze
all the creative juice out of an idea
but you gotta build the show you got to
keep the trains running and and you
cannot reinvent television every episode
so depending on your show like there's a
formula there's three or four different
formulas if you're doing a procedural
and BAM so I mean it's gotta get
murdered in ant1 the other have your mr.
direct in act two you gotta meet the
person who actually did it by act 3 and
you gotta have your red herring in for
and you gotta figure out who did in five
like and that's every [ __ ] mystery
you watch any show any police procedural
the third person your detectives meet
did it it's almost always the third
person the Murder She Wrote rule yeah
it's like now the first one is the third
person I [ __ ] did it yeah like
that's how you do that that's how you do
500 episodes of a TV show you know
there's a formula there's a constant
structure in order to fill that much I
mean it's different in prestige TV like
Game of Thrones I have a formula other
and the episode before the finale is
when all the big [ __ ] will happen and
the finale is day Newmont but by and
large they're just telling one big
season long story just like in a movie a
week right but if you're doing anything
that has to recur and with that the
flash has a formula you know and doesn't
solve it yeah Tiffany what I would love
it if rain Kyle Oh Luke but if you got
two cents couldn't they take out one
last one old a slash yeah with a robot
hand you got two young locks and chair
like that that's true that's what I
would like to see I want to see Chewie
take out kylo Ren because kylo Ren took
out Chuy's boyfriend and history and the
kid but who's been with him longer than
Chewie and he seemed really [ __ ] yeah
pissed and hurt like you you know he's
got one [ __ ] before but when he did
it you could feel the [ __ ] loss and
and then you know he tried to take out
kylo Ren who's a wonderful Internet car
to not forget who drew it but it showed
depicted that scene where Chu he's about
to [ __ ] shoot Halloran and then he
thinks back to like when kylo Ren was a
kid and she was hanging out and stuff
and then he lips that were lowers like
essentially he could have killed him in
[ __ ] didn't I thought that was so
[ __ ] beautiful that's not in the
movie that's somebody's interpretation
of it in the movie I think he was trying
to hit him in the [ __ ] head
got too much hair in his eyes hi that'd
be great that'd be fantastic well you
know that's not gonna be the case
could you imagine they sell toys to a
bunch of kids like hey kids
[Laughter]
but I hope so kylo Ren why do you think
I saw so many online say I think they're
brother and sister
which one Warner Brothers
hey just the league looks great we lost
the show do you think they knew when
they started I think they would have to
I don't know I mean they're Russian
George did not know they were sisters
making that [ __ ] up as we go I think it
would be too easy if they were brother
and sister like that it's it's too
obvious for that to be the thing yeah I
thought at the end of force awakens I
kept saying oh it's Luke's daughter
because she just came she found her dad
she's like down here's your [ __ ]
laser dick back but then somebody was
like why do you think somebody started
saying oh my god JJ tell you that that's
his daughter Isaac no I just that's what
I assumed what I watched it and then
people a lot of people seem to think
she's a cannoli she's been you know B
hence the accent and then some people
online
these are none of my organs I read
people online having these arguments
they said that no she's got an accent
from
guy that they left her with on Jack who
that dude is like you'll get oh poor
Simon Simon because then they put it out
online they're like kids aren't born
with an accent yeah she would pick that
even if she was Kenobi's kid she would
have picked it up from that dude on Jack
who I spent a lot of time reading
people's theories I could tell I had a
day job so where we going next right
there holy Sh appreciative responder my
favorite so I can't take credit for it
but somebody pointed out to me the first
French journalist I ever sat down with
in can with cashiers du cinéma they said
they talked to this guy and I said I
can't speak French so like you barely
speaks English so it's gonna be fun and
I said what do you possibly have to say
to see clerks I was like why why would
he want to talk to his movie set in New
Jersey sure like that so like I don't
know sit down find out I'm sat down to
do Doolittle French's cigarette bag in
his back pocket might as well and then
he had shirts at war inside sit down
with he inhales a cigarette because the
Cheyennes son involved is there not like
a modern-day r2d2 and c3po know and i
was like oh my god my french brother for
my mother another whatever that thing is
but it wasn't the case I didn't intend
that but once he said it I was like
that's so smart and so every interview
after that I'd be like well of course
Jane saw Bob we met to represent c-3po
and r2d2 wasn't the intention but it
wound up being what they were
they carried through all the movies and
stuff like the Druids you should have to
say it in a French accent from now on I
think about like if they were indeed are
Jay and Silent Bob were r2d2 and c3po we
want one better than them because r2d2
and c3po never had their own movie right
I mean unless you count the cartoon
droids nobody counts droids nobody
nobody counts towards home Amy worked on
Joyce the great pauldini who wrote we
all sometimes have to cash a check I
think he was happy to be talked about
like very like he's a big star Wars fan
so we got to work under Lucas which
sounds dirtier than I had to you know
this show must be hell for you right oh
that's why she is such a fiendish
character base time I've seen the
trailer and I know that story it
celebrates the women that influenced
Professor Marsden to come up with the
character for those that don't follow
was William Marshall William Moulton
Marston
most most most Ingold Moulton Marston
Moulton Lane the character of Wonder
Woman he also created the lie detector
the polygraph test that's why Wonder
Woman has a magic lasso of truth he was
obsessed with the notion of truth
he was also obsessed with strapping
people to chairs yes he was a big
believer that women should run the world
and men were inferior and that the world
would be a better place with strong
women in charge so the opening issues of
Wonder Woman depict a lot of bondage for
that reason women bonding men up and
stuff like that binding minute
also he lived with two women I he was
married and and had a girl famila to the
three-way relationship polyamorous I'm
not even cold these days but his wife
wore silver bracelets so like through
the movie they piece together how Wonder
Woman came to be you know came to me
through a guy who's like these women are
the greatest thing in the world and he
kind of seemed like he could combine the
best parts of the miniature so I think
the movies gonna be a celebration the
care I don't think it does anything to
hurt it I think makes a lot of people go
[ __ ] that's where it came from that's
interesting I'm yes the book what's his
name Grant Morrison when he was on track
now Batman
talked about the book years ago he's a
big fan of the he also did a Wonder
Woman story so he's doing a deep dive on
the character and he was explaining he
told me all that [ __ ] about the
backstory he's like the guy who created
him living with two women I was into
bondage and like what like Bob Kane
stories boring tonight okay we're good
right there yes I'm so boring I would
choose Boba Fett just because you know
like oh he looks great
they always have been you don't know a
lot about him and [ __ ] like that yeah
and also for sentimental reasons I
choose both of you know for Pete what
about you you really belong with us
among the stars Lando how did you land
on all [ __ ] day long
Lando or for the Mon Calamari ball Akbar
would you do it him present like that is
a George doing when he's young like how
he got so anxious I would do like a
famine would you like a mockumentary
like yeah I would do that when I was a
kid I imagine they had to go into the
water I mean you'd think they're
trucking calamari yeah okay I go up in
genuine les they take the job away from
me because I just didn't have a suit a
super girl and so maybe they watching
the light you [ __ ] stuff but it airs
tonight it's happening probably probably
already happened yeah flash season two
premieres you missed it to be here sure
thank God for DVRs who watches it on
time anyway
although a bunch of people do because
like when when it's on I know it cuz my
Twitter feed like lights up and stuff so
I guess people do honor the TV schedule
somewhere in the world like I don't
there's very few shows maybe Game of
Thrones that's the one where I'm like I
will watch this one it's a but generally
everything outside catch up to when I
went to last night on earth is one of
the few that I want you or like live
really cuz my son is in love with it
yeah which he should not be but because
it's a little heady for a
thirteen-year-old sometimes literally
yeah and Game of Thrones but that's
about it
did really is he doesn't watch that yeah
so
now hearing care about dragons I know it
breaks my heart who the [ __ ] are you
dragons are [ __ ] no I like down you
know I mean it's certainly no parallel
but I grew up in the 70s of course and
before I saw Empire
I saw another film about dealing with
loss a movie that didn't end happily but
was still a celebration movie was great
but it didn't give you that satisfying
ending that you're supposed to get when
you go to a movie theater because that
was one of my favorite movies of all
time not that's not the only reason
there were kids cursing and it was
called the Bad News Bears Bad News Bears
taught my generation how to lose like it
was a story about kids who were unlikely
and then [ __ ] somehow beat the odds
and made it to like the big game and
ship and came within spitting [ __ ]
distance and then exported and then it
is that age they tried to sit there in a
theater and you know watch them [ __ ]
lose and it was I don't know it shaped
it shaped us I think as a generation in
the moment like I would go back and see
it again and again hoping that like this
time they're gonna [ __ ] win you know
but it was always that was the lesson of
that movie was like hey man it's just a
game like you don't always get to win
sometimes [ __ ] other people win and
yet sometimes they're like just
literally better than you I can't
[ __ ] out that or sometimes because
your coach makes the worst [ __ ] call
of all time and decides that's the day
everybody should play you know instead
of like waiting for the day after they
win the trophy with but it was an
important lesson man and and I think
that when I saw Empire Strikes Back
it spoke to me on the same level like
this in [ __ ] movie that ends down
like you know now everything [ __ ]
works out and they lost the battle but
the star war is not quite over yet so I
think I'll always feel for it for that
reason because of the Bad News Bears
it's when the 70s were big for that like
I think in America in the 70s everybody
was broke fuel crisis like Jimmy Carter
was president and people thought he was
[ __ ] it up
but the idea that you could lose but
still win in the process that effort is
what counter akhi is the same way rocky
doesn't win at the end of rocky but
here's the point I don't know I point to
rocky instead of the bad news but
probably because as a child like Rocky's
an adult so there was nothing for me
there so then I'm also not an aggressive
person so I was never like yeah I want
to fight like Rocky and [ __ ] but the Bad
News Bears like I could be fat like the
one kid yeah the idea that you could
refrain for yourself what victory was
that that it did not mean like I all I
got to do was stay on my feet all I
gotta do was try as hard as I can try
and there's nobility in the effort which
felt like I'm assuming bunch of adults
felt in the 70s which was I'm not living
a life as good as my parents were like
we're in the middle of a recession and
fuel crisis and I'm on line to get a
gallon of gas and the job is they pay me
what he used to but all I gotta be was
get up every morning to try and it feels
like Empire was a culmination of that
decade of [ __ ] man if I just get up and
do this one more time maybe it'll break
my way maybe if it doesn't I [ __ ]
gave him my best
wait I don't know I mean I don't think
anybody yet feels like America is as bad
off as it was in the 70s what [ __ ]
experience the world I mean it's it's
worse now
I mean it's worse now but people don't
really live in 70 I don't think they
feel it as as
viscerally as they did in the 70s and
because I think that's when the regions
where the 80s were so go-go cocaine
crazy well
oh [ __ ] Wall Street is paying off we can
all invest we can all get our piece of
the American dream
and it's hookers and testarossa's and
mobile phones and Miami Vice like that's
the life we're gonna live in the 90s
we're [ __ ] first we're gonna live the
best lives ever and now we're in this
like [ __ ] the real estate crisis almost
destroyed everything we almost lost the
auto crisis like terrorism is on the
rise like hey aids it's not as bad as we
think it is except it's kind of worse
but we don't notice oh we were gonna
[ __ ] bury our heads in pop culture be
happy tonight man you burn up the 70s
I'm just helping I I saw a Jackie Earle
Haley he was part of the tip panel for
the int gate and so people in the panel
ended I got to talkin as it was ending I
got to show them out it was like hey man
before we get out of here at some point
out Jackie O Ali isn't one of my
favorite movies of all time and I'm sure
he aids here another point but like I've
never had that moment I never got to
thank God we were on stage because
otherwise I would just wept in his arms
like Kelly leak you know so I said to
him and I said to the crowd I was like
that movie like taught me how to lose as
child and I've been a loser ever [ __ ]
sense so thank you for that but I think
I think that's why that's yeah but you
also TransAm z-- those were cool that's
true Burt Reynolds
I made it all better yeah nice job
Wow move very question movie scene that
affected me the most I think of a few
this movie called the world according to
GARP which is wonderful
and my old man say can you see it when I
was not age-appropriate at all and I
felt like a cool thing like he trusted
me enough to watch this movie wasn't
racing movie but there's some [ __ ] in it
that like you wouldn't show necessarily
an 11 year old somebody gets their dick
off in a car accident [ __ ] like that so
there was a moment in the movie where a
young guard TS part that's where I got
the ts name and Moritz young TS car his
grandparents died he grew up without a
denim shirt his bling clothes as his mom
and she's wonderfully accenture Jenny
feels this nurse who writes this
feminist tome that like takes over the
world and she becomes one of the world's
most famous people so young GARP there
at the family house and her parents died
and so they're sitting on the steps the
of the house and the young heart says to
his mother he goes now you don't have
the father either because he's never had
a father so alive and she goes nope and
they talk about death and she goes it'll
come for everybody
it'll come for you one day she will come
for me but she's like you shouldn't be
afraid of she's like that's not the I
can't do it exactly where she goes what
did she say she goes it's not she got
everybody dies guard it's about having a
life before you die and even at age 11 I
was like there it is somebody just said
the realest [ __ ] thing I've ever heard
in my life like we are all gonna die but
have a life before you die and she said
that to occator that goes on throughout
the movie and has this like [ __ ] epic
life so I always remember that like you
know there are movie moments of course
like [ __ ] either lightsaber battle
and impartial
I love you I know and [ __ ] like that but
that didn't shape me as an individual
that just gave me [ __ ] to talk about my
[ __ ] but I love but a moment like that
shaped me as an individual you when I
was a kid my dad took me see Star Wars
this is not a Star Wars story but he
took me to see Star Wars realized how
much I love Star Wars and then took me
to every space movie that ever released
into theaters good bad and indifferent
myself I saw Battlestar Galactica in the
theater I saw Star Trek the motion
picture and fell asleep
I saw battle beyond the stars but he
took me to see flash board
in 1980 and there's a moment in the
movie when flash is on our Borya because
he's hiding out from Ming the Merciless
and and princess aura decided I'm gonna
take you to see my boyfriend because
that's a great idea
and so he's hiding along with with
Prince Barin and his flunkies and he's
got to take the test of manhood that
they give everybody on our board sir on
our way so he he sticks his hand in the
stump right and inside the stump you see
the [ __ ] fleshy thong with a giant
[ __ ] pincer and and you see I do do
it beforehand get stung [ __ ] James
Bond just slices him with a sword when
he falls down
so flash I have to stick his hand in and
I'm on the edge of my [ __ ] seat
because I've never seen this much peril
in my entire life and I'm like dad I
think you know I think they kill Flash
Gordon
he goes no they they never kill the hero
and I said who's ding and it was the
first time I had ever realized that
there were people who made these things
like I just assumed that this was like
documentary whatever the [ __ ] we go to
the movies like this this is amazing
what is that stuff don't do it but that
was the first time I realized that this
was a job people had that people make
this stuff and and that it's possible
that I could maybe make this stuff too
so that is that is the scene that that
that probably set me on the path it made
me and there were at least it made me
pay attention and maybe it made me
understand and should these credits mean
something this is not just the time you
go to the bathroom that these are
actually people who did something you
know this is not the unknown we got like
five minutes before the movie starts
because all these [ __ ] credits are
gonna go it's it's this is a job this is
a this is a life people leave and if i
play my cards right I could have this
job too I was just your father you've
been a parent I just like I don't
remember ever having a conversation with
my own child going another's shits like
you just assumed that when you kids
start watching [ __ ] they'll understand
like your dad just assumes like did you
pants again almost killed a hero again
but my son will especially always
younger like this is all fake right it's
like yeah but it's not fake fake because
you would get super [ __ ] tense and he
just not be down with it so they're not
gonna kill that guy right now but it's
all fake okay I just had the rice guy in
my head for a second that you do it up
[Laughter]
that was a long road for that joke but I
appreciate called porgy and bess but
[ __ ] you mm-hmm any job you don't even
have to pay me man as long as I get to
wear hockey jersey I'll [ __ ] show I
have not have you washed your belayer I
watched Star Trek but I haven't watched
the work well then you've seen the Orval
if you've seen Star Trek they're talking
straight-up honest adaptation I mean
listen like it feels as if the URL is
for people who don't know how to type
next generation into a search bar but I
will say this my son hates Star Trek he
loves the Orval because it's not Star
Trek except it's totally starching this
is my car on track your mileage may vary
but I actually think it's it's it's kind
of a pretty nice tribute I think it's
mostly pointless given that there are
700 hours of Star Trek that already
exist but it's kind of fun not as funny
as it should be not as serious as it
should be but it's it's this weird
middle ground we don't want to make a
comedy we don't make a drama we're just
gonna make what Seth wants to make which
is legit because he's got 87 billion
dollars so if he wants a TV show where
he's a captain he gets a TV show he's a
captain but I do feel that's a little
bit tits on a bull except I don't mind
tits or both so we're used to giving you
props as a writer not for that
yeah I have not checked about yet we go
check it out based on that whatever that
was I don't know if he's been on it yet
he said he wasn't in it for the first
few episodes but he plays a space
bartender I know he showed up yet you'll
see him when he does you know we won't
see him apparently he says he doesn't
[ __ ] look a thing like him so says he
spends a lot of time in makeup and stuff
I mean if this is the entry vector that
gets people to go back to that classic
Trek then I'm all for how I spell it
it's not like a runaway hit but I think
the expectations were relatively low for
it so probably I think if only to keep
stepping for all and happy and what is
nobody knows how treks doing the the the
episode that aired on CBS did pretty
well I think it got like eight point
nine million viewers which in this day
and age qualifies as a hit right yeah so
much so that you think they were just
[ __ ] put it on CBS but no they're
driving to the a challenge so and nobody
will ever know how those episodes are
doing on the app which one discovery
Star Trek we did I liked I thought the
Klingons were a little much but like
it's been it's felt like they did too
much this sounds stupid but way too much
makeup on the Klingons like they seem to
over thought that not just the
headpieces but also their outfits they
kind of look quasi Shakespeare in the
show like that and it felt like it gave
the actors very limited mobility with
with characters so much makeup you're so
much stiff body work here with the suit
and I also felt like you know like I get
it Klingons a real fake language and
it's cool if you can do a whole scene in
it but it gets a little like much right
like could you imagine if you the actor
how you play one of those Klingon show
like oh my god I'm gonna be on Star Trek
everyone be like I didn't see who are
you and you're like I was the Klingons
like I didn't hear you they're like why
they speak English like they
pushed in on their face like in hunt for
October you'd speak in Russian they push
in also they speak so much issue but I
understand the show is sold
internationally so it probably balloons
them to let the Klingons just be Klingon
that way there's one less thing to
translate when they should overseas
maybe that's my guess
or somebody's a real big purist that you
know they got buckets be going on was I
the only one that bumped into that I
stand all right that means yes
so we could probably I'll just be here
at the bar way back see weed so for
those that don't probably Morgan but
this story was unavoidable this week
they did that season premiere had you
know a joke about Szechuan sauce the
sauce that McDonald's had done for Mulan
back in the day and now the moment they
did the joke in the episode you knew
like so sooner or later who's gonna
happen but you know it was just they
were too intense about it no but the
whole remember he's like that's my
one-armed man warty Szechuan sauce like
so you don't sooner or later [ __ ]
McDonald's would would be like yeah why
not let's just pull it out of marbles or
hot waffles so they say it like for one
day only this [ __ ] wine sauce is going
to be available and she had an every
Rick and Morty fan on the planet lined
up around
Donald's and then the amounts like
massive disappointment because some
stores only got like 20 packets and
there were a thousand people lined up so
police were pulled into some races
people were chanting we want the songs
and cops were like you know dispersed
return to your homes
it was kind of crazy so you know number
one I don't know how they rate that show
in terms of how they figure out who's
watching but I say the show is
definitely a hit if it made a bunch of
people like go to McDonald's for sure
one sauce so much so that it made the
news like that's that's a massive fandom
and now they've announced that they're
bringing it back like they realize they
[ __ ] up everyone went after them
they're a bunch of people online went to
eat at every other fast-food place eaten
chicken into the camera and [ __ ] to tell
McDonald's [ __ ] you so it looks like
they're bringing it back again this time
more volume they should just hand it to
the [ __ ] menu one at least for like a
year
then you drop it off but man that's
that's a powerful fan base right there
that's powerful cartoon if it shifted
corporations you know [ __ ] year leave
one iota it like when they announced
that they were going to do it I was like
Jesus that's it's a massive ship I can't
just make quick [ __ ] turns like this
big deal to turn on the Chevron sauce
machine again for 50 bucks on eBay it
went up to a thousand bucks
that's sweet money that is a bunch of
college kids we don't have a rude
awakening when the real world shows up
you see this I've hit a thousand dollars
for it they call me Gen Y
[Laughter]
yeah AMC didn't pick it up for a second
cycle they they not a bad thing at all
they you know their feeling was and
they're absolutely right you know Chris
had that space on the network and he
hadn't done talking with Chris Hardwick
yet but he doesn't talk him dead I'm
talking preacher and talking everything
else so it makes more sense he's got
that time slot and then people are
already watching feed in to that so you
know I got like I honestly was shocked
that they gave that show a run wall
because I'm Mike's away looks like two
middle-aged white guys are gonna top I'm
talking about pop culture
like that's can't you do that you can
watch that for free on the internet
left and right and sure so I was
surprised yes yes it's exactly why
didn't he came then I was like good lord
man like this we need some tie purse to
the upbeat music so so I you know I was
always surprised made on the I love the
show I love what we did with it and
stuff particularly with Tiffany brought
to it but it was surprising to me that
even existed I was brought into that
very late like Gregg and his company had
pitched that show and AMC liked it and
then they were like well we like it but
like would you think about using Kevin
Smith as goes because we have my
countless men and we like mister so I
was the last second to last element
added to that show and then I was like
we gotta bring somebody else and it
suggests Tiffany because I sat down and
took me on Fandango and I think made me
on DC all-access and [ __ ] and Tiffany
knows and [ __ ] and Tiffany's like
[ __ ] super smart when it comes to
stupid [ __ ] so you know she was a great
welcome addition to the show but when
they didn't pick it up I was never like
no I was like yeah I guess I'm shocked
we even got as many episodes as we did
so yeah it won't be back sir don't you
see up to great number he'll start
crying you'll just have to make do with
us
yeah and then over there yeah no no we
see you he was raising it for you
he's your hand eraser he's like I'll
race before you is he your man I agree
with you but I'll just put on Front
Street January we start shooting James
sound reboot yeah so January office
opens up probably by February 1st for
Rolling Stone
Louisiana yes we're going to shoot at
hook it's and it's good I like it very
much moment big Kevin Smith fan so of
course I would like it but it's funny
it's very very funny that much like well
we'll see hopefully ladies and gentlemen
have you had good times we have last
time we did this but last time we did
this like we went two and a half hours
and by the end of it I was like this is
the moves man like instead of us
shooting the show at home like let's
just do it there no we did would be yeah
and you get to it like shoot a long show
and it cut it up into segments to put it
up online and stuff so we decided to try
doing it here on a regular basis and you
guys tonight just made it for real when
you sold the place out like what a day
two days so and then the new one went up
on sale and people start buying that up
it looks like that's and so as well so I
love doing it if it feels like it's less
performance oriented for me like you
know when I do battle on them like let's
put on a [ __ ] child this feels like
we're doing the show that we would
normally do at home but with a nod
and participating and it actually helps
drive the content forward because we
find out [ __ ] that other people want to
talk about if he hadn't talked about the
writers thing like we wouldn't have
gotten to that other space and what was
the other thing I just talked Oh
favorite movie scene about favorite
movie saying I was [ __ ] beautiful and
so I wouldn't have thought to ask him
that so I'm glad somebody with brains
was here to answer that so I've enjoyed
doing this show for the last two weeks
here and we're gonna keep going man you
guys have made it a real welcome I'm
Mark Barnard
tune in next week same time same fat
channels podcast.com or the attempt at
comms labs Kevin Smith
may the force be with you folks tonight
stomach
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you